well it took some time it took some
effort but they have a deal there's jj
watt outside nrg stadium they are ready
to roll training camps open tomorrow
they open with several days of covet 19
testing it will be a gradual
phase-in period a ramp up period no
one's putting pads on until the middle
of august chris that's usually when
we're halfway through the preseason no
preseason at all this year as everyone
gets ready for week one and that's going
to be the focus getting all the players
ready for week one either with 80 guys
from the get-go or if you go with 90 you
can have 90 until august 16 you have to
have a split squad i think most teams
are probably going to opt to just have
80 and keep everyone together the
commissioner said after the deal was
reached friday night training camps will
begin as scheduled we are committed to
playing a safe and complete 2020 season
and i think that word complete
i i think that word can be interpreted
in multiple ways it doesn't mean
256 games it just means we're going to
complete it with a super bowl
championship that is given to someone
just like in 1982 when there were nine
regular season games due to the strike
1987 when they were replacement players
for multiple weeks and 15 regular season
games right nobody puts an asterisk on
those lombardi trophies who knows what
will happen this year but they're going
forward and i think that that even if
there are hiccups along the way even if
there are outbreaks along the way even
if they have to cancel individual games
or entire weeks they're committed to
getting this season in
completed
with someone winning the super bowl and
then move on to 2021 yeah well i i
appreciate you know their their
stubbornness that way i do they are
committed and you know it's something we
hit on in the open and you know i do
think that
you know
hey nfl coaches front office people
they're a little frustrated because a
lot of this stuff is just getting
figured out and they don't have all the
laws of the land but they're starting to
see a little bit here
come about and they're starting to get a
feel for how things are going to go down
you know these guys are in their
facilities for the most part they're
seeing what's being done you know to
make it all work and you know just
talking from really talking and texting
to a few of my friends throughout the
league i think all of them feel
yeah better now that they've been in the
office and seen what's going down here
so we'll see it was a major step
certainly that they got some of these
details figured out now
you know the big thing to me here is i
know we said we're starting on time
right we're starting on time but we're
not really starting on time because
they're going to get there right and
then it's going to be four or five days
of having to go through some certain
protocols which to me this is where i
just worry about it like okay so now
it's four or five days and let's maybe
it doesn't happen to six or seven days
so everything gets figured out you know
now we're going into this period of
we're gonna train and get ready
and then okay now the pads period has
been bumped back just a little farther
and i just i just hope we can get it all
in before week one that's the only thing
i'm worried about right now as an
ex-player and a guy that worries about
the players and all of that what do you
mean by getting it all in well just get
the players ready having them ready to
go and really saying that they're
physically in shape and ready to take on
the physical rigors of of the nfl
football season just as we've talked
about with years without you know the
last cba deal you know you said it last
week injury rates were up what a little
over 25
i just worry about that that's all i'm
saying but either way i do feel a lot
more confident about some of the steps
that have been put in place here as of
late
well that's why they didn't want to have
a preseason because you didn't want to
rush guys onto a field in a game setting
when they have limited opportunity to be
as
as healthy and prepared as they could be
but you know i i and this is something
that i think we need to be thinking
about and talking about in the coming
weeks
how many teams will treat this like a
12-game season with a four-game
preseason it just so happens those four
games in september count in the
standings but will we see
for example in chicago where they don't
know who the starting quarterback is
going to be will we see both nick foles
and mitchell trubisky in september
instead of august when the competition
would have been resolved will we see
a rotation more aggressively on an
offensive line where some backups get
real playing time in september will we
see more use of the reserves
uh for two reasons number one your
starters may not be in ideal shape and
number two
doesn't it make sense to have every guy
on your roster
at least in some sort of game shape and
some sort of game preparedness in the
event that there's a guy who is
otherwise a starting offensive lineman
who is positive for covert 19 and now
the backup gets thrown into the fray at
least he would have been playing some so
chris i think that
that this unique year
needs to get teams thinking very
differently about the first month of the
season it's almost a hybrid regular
season preseason from the standpoint of
making sure your guys are ready for
october november december yeah no well i
think that's the one thing that's jumped
out to me mike just from talking to
people around the nfl you know the the
you're going into training camp this
year
and really what's happening is
you're going let's get ready for week
one that's all you're worried about and
so
you're going to see high level
game planning and really all your eggs
and the let's get ready for week one and
try to win that game basket and to me
that's where it also i look at and just
just just another thought that came to
my head whether you got 80 or 90 guys
and because you got no pre-season and
things like that too i just feel like a
lot of those back end roster guys are
going to get used this summer more than
ever you know they're going to be used
really to go and hey you know oh yeah
you got a chance to make the team
wink wink but we really need you over
there for scout team for the 70th rep
today because we're trying to win week
one and we kind of know the 53 that's
gonna make the team yeah there's seven
or eight of you on there that we're not
sure about but we kind of know so we're
going to get them ready and we're going
to kind of use the rest of you on the
back end to just help us get ready and
that's unfortunate because you know some
of those back end guys we know are not
going to get a chance to play in the
preseason or maybe get the reps as they
usually would in free agency late draft
picks that might make a team but that's
so be it and i think that's going to be
more of the approaches this year maybe
we'll see
let me add this point to that right to
the extent that one of those guys at the
back end of the roster sufficiently
flashes and you get to a comfort level
with him during training camp that you
could maybe roll with him as a starter
or a key contributor the opportunity is
going to be presented
to shed expensive veterans
save money in a year where you're not
going to be getting your regular game
day revenue yeah and bump cap space to
next year one of the realities of this
new deal is the fact that they've
already accounted for next year being
down and the salary cap would have been
as low as 130 million dollars per team
even if they play all the games what
they've done through this agreement they
have guaranteed that the salary cap will
be no lower than 175 million that's
still 23 million plus lower than it is
this year so any cap dollars you save
this year can be kicked to next year to
give you more room to breathe and there
are some teams out there like the eagles
saints falcons chiefs steelers bears
raiders vikings all according to
overthecap.com they're going to be in a
mess next year under the salary cap if
they have that young guy
that they can pay six hundred thousand
dollars to this year and they can move
on from a veteran that's due to make six
million or squeeze him into taking 2
million
every dollar saved this year is real
money in the bank and it's salary caps
based on the ledger for next year so i
the cynical side of me
is i agree with you that a lot of these
guys are going to be cannon fodder
but whoever shows they can be more than
cannon fodder is going to have a chance
to make the team because as it relates
to management of your roster there's an
opportunity there to shed some expensive
salaries and create some cab space for
next year yeah no i it's a very real
aspect mike it's something that i still
probably haven't wrapped my head around
yet to think about it all the way like
you know even as i was going through my
spiel you know and as soon as you cut in
there i knew you were gonna go there and
i was like you know you're right it's
it's it's going to be a thing this year
we're going to see
some names that i don't think we expect
to see come cut time in the nfl because
of some of those issues and what you're
talking about too and also you know
i don't know how this affects coaches or
whatever it may be here but when you
talk about those bottom roster guys
you're getting down to your final 53 and
most like we've said most teams know
going into training camp
the 42 43 guys that are gonna make the
team and there's just you know seven
eight ten spots that are kind of up for
grabs you know this is a year where
yeah you're gonna the coaches gonna have
to take a little bit more of a guess
than normal you know i don't know if
they're gonna get the true evaluation of
some of those guys and you know they're
just gonna have to kind of take a shot
in the dark with the guy that they feel
the most comfortable with or maybe it
comes down to like what you're saying
okay yeah here's a veteran we're a
little more comfortable with by just a
smidgen over a young guy but oh that
veteran's making a ton of money compared
to that young guy all right the hell
with that veteran who's just a smidgen
better let's get rid of them and go with
the young guy and i think you're right
those are the that that's the hopeful
thing for those guys this year uh that
maybe gives them a little bit of benefit
the doubt and the fact that they didn't
get to prove themselves in otas and
training camp
hey we don't know what kind of shape
these veterans are in as they walk
through the door the coaches are either
going to be impressed or they're going
to be saying holy crap what did you eat
over the last six months because they
have not been around these guys at all
one last thing before we take a break we
got plenty more to talk about as relates
to the nfl nflpa agreement
the agreement consists of a specific
list of prohibited activities oh yes
look i think it's it's there for a
deterrent effect right i i doubt anyone
other than the patriots is going to have
security tailing guys to see if they go
to the nightclub or or or do any of
these other things you can't go to
indoor nightclubs indoor bars except to
pick up food indoor house parties with
15 or more people indoor concerts
professional sporting events other than
presumably your own or indoor church
services that allow attendance above 25
percent of capacity you can be fined if
you test positive they can fight whether
or not they have to pay you you can have
guaranteed money that's forfeited i
really do think that this is just a way
to scare the young players into not
doing things they shouldn't do i now i
don't the teams aren't going to say that
but from our perspective we look at and
say well it's going to be a pain in the
butt to fight your players on whether or
not they broke these rules the reality
is this is your hammer when the coach
or the veteran quarterback is saying to
these guys you go home and you stay home
every night for five months yeah that's
right you know this applies a little
more guilt to the situation too you know
like if some guy does do wrong or do
that hey we got rules we've read you the
rules you know the rules they're right
there on the walls you walk out of the
locker room every day but the big thing
will be this to me and this is why i
like to i agree with what you're saying
the end of the day
i think the locker room is going to
police itself that's what i think is
going to happen you know i think
self-police itself yeah self-police
itself and this is where i call on the
fletcher cox's and the aaron donald's
and the khalil max of the world to where
you know if you hear guys on the team
that you feel like are not acting
appropriately outside of the facility
damn you got to lay the smackdown you
got to let them know it's just not
acceptable
i mean there's really there's no other
way to say it those the veteran leaders
on these teams are going to have to keep
the young guys in check and do their
best to stay on top of them and make
them feel you know threatened or scared
a little bit that they might ruin
everybody's season and have that guilt
laying over them that way hey and here's
the other thing too right anywhere these
guys go right people are going to have
these and tmz is going to be very happy
right there's going to be a lot of
citizen journalism we are all big
brother in this what about the hotline i
think they should have a hotline too i
like that the nba does that where the
players can call on other players you
know and and you know be anonymous and
telling each other
and here's the thing the way they've
done this deal you get paid as you play
if games are scrapped
you don't get paid for that game yeah so
if there's only 14 weeks in the season
you lose
2 16 of your salary and you've got an
incentive yes collectively all players
in the league have an incentive and it's
not just it's not just tom brady in the
tampa bay buccaneers it's every player
on every team because if they start
saying at week three we can't do it week
seven we can't do it and they end up
playing 13 games 12 games whatever
they all lose so that's the ultimate
incentive not just wanting to play
football but wanting your money yeah
that is what is going to keep these
younger guys in line and i think some of
the guys that may get the final roster
spots i think the gm and the coach need
to put their heads together and say can
we trust this guy yeah we trust this guy
right the talent's relatively equal
right but do we trust this guy yeah
right this guy's married i think he's
got a couple of little kids right he's
gonna go home and he's gonna stay home
this guy's single
and we've gotten to know him a little
bit yeah he likes and he seems like he
likes having a good time right right and
it seems like he's got you know he gives
in to his friends right and uh you know
we're gonna keep this guy instead and i
think that the veteran leadership on the
team is gonna lobby for that too they're
gonna want a locker room full of guys
who can be trusted yes to act like
professionals chris that's going to be a
real dynamic this year yeah i totally
agree mike i think it is you know i
think teams gm's head coaches have got
to think about that aspect and you know
i think you're right the incentive about
just knowing to go man if i smart and
you know don't do anything stupid here i
can continue to get paid and get paid
big checks and and continue my life and
and further my career and i think that
is a big incentive but yeah i think it's
going to be on the players and the teams
and the coaches to really to hold these
guys accountable and stay on their butts
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports